hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen if you haven't heard 2016
was recently named the international
year of the pulse and no I'm not talking
about your heartbeat that's something
you want to celebrate every year but
pulses actually include all your dried
peas chickpeas beans and lentils and
their nutritional powerhouse is packed
with fiber and protein and if the first
thing you think about when you hear the
word beans is the magic fruit the more
you eat the more you
well actually guys it's not true more
eat the less you're gonna - so eat up
we are seeing pulses appear on
restaurant menus all over the world even
celebrity chefs are finding ways to
incorporate pulses into their recipes so
to celebrate the year of the pulse
thousands of people all over the world
are taking the pulse pledge promising to
enjoy pulses at least once a day for 10
weeks straight thankfully I've parted up
with my favorite pulse ox knack Sabra
hummus to bring you some of the easiest
ways to meet your pulse target let's get
started
tip 1 make black bean soup in a flash I
heat a few cans of black beans with
jarred salsa the vegetable broth chili
powder and cumin
then I puree it into a smooth soup and
serve it top with avocado
plain Greek yogurt and cilantro tip -
paca hummus snack pack a container of
Saveur hummus and whole-grain crackers
for your purse
office desk or gym bag the combination
of fiber protein and carbs is going to
help you get through any workout or that
3p an energy depth tip 3 upgrade your
avocado toast with white beans add
protein to this trendy breakfast by
pureeing a can of white beans with
avocado lemon juice parsley basil garlic
and oil and smearing on whole grain
toast tip 4 bring fiber and protein to
your cookout with hummus burgers mix
together a quarter cup of sauteed onions
with 1 pound of lean ground beef and a
quarter cup of roasted red pepper Sabra
hummus form into patties grill until
cooked through and serve on whole grain
buns smeared with a little more hummus
tip five boost protein in your Bolognese
just add a can of cooked lentils to your
favorite pasta sauce and serve it on a
bed of spaghetti how do you plan to take
the pulse pledge leave me a message
below or tweet some your favorite
recipes to me using the hashtag pulse
pledge thank you so much for watching
more great meal and snack ideas be sure
to subscribe to my channel and I'll see
you next time on Abbey's kitchen